аграрії в шоці новий черговий терор маєш
вийти в Тінь маєш ховатися вам не
соромно зараз взагалі ці речі говорити
тут в залі я розумію чому опозиція так
не любить нас Ви цього хочете він всіх
переконує він на вас як удав діє
голосуйте ви робите це як завжди
підведемо короткий підсумок роботи
Верховної ради І саме розгляд
економічних питань на засіданнях
Верховної
Ради перше на що треба звернути увагу
щодо особливостій оподаткування банків
прибутків банків ви мабуть чули про те
що банківська система отримала за
місяців 2023 року майже 100 млрд
прибутків і Насправді все було
зосереджено на тому скільки держава має
отримати в державний бюджет податку з
цього прибутку за результатами 2023 року
правда трошки заднім числом поду податок
на прибуток буде становити
50%. починаючи з
2024го і всі наступні роки норма яка не
обмежена воєнним станом періодом
воєнного стану буде
25%. що важливо для мене в цьому проекті
закону я подавала до цього проекту також
декілька поправок які не були враховані
на жаль але які стосувалися якраз
платників податків прозорості роботи
податкового органу кожного разу в ці
проекти попадають інші норми і які не
стосуються піднятих в основному законі в
першому читанні статей і таким чином
новорічна ялинка майже в кожному проекті
закону звісно ці поправки не стосуються
особливостей оподаткування банків звісно
сама дискусія навколо тих ставок які
запропоновані цим проектом це 20 50% за
результатами за 23-й рік і 25% починаючи
з результатів за 2 четвертий рік
дискусійні норми Але зараз я не хочу
говорити про них я все ж таки про
відношення в комітеті до поправок які
надають можливості додаткові можливості
платникам податків і чомусь вони не
приймаються почула на комітеті що навіть
не будуть підтримані ті норми які
стосуються такої зараз величезної
проблеми тих громадян які знаходяться в
населених пунктах в територіальних гро
ромадах щодо яких прийнято рішення про
обов'язкову евакуацію населення ви
уявляєте обов'язкова евакуація населення
а податок на землю виставляється для цих
громадян дійсно ті рішення які ми
приймаємо у військовий час вони не
завжди є ідеальними і не завжди є
бездоганними наступний проект закону
який став уже законом це якраз питання
внесення змін в закон про споживче
кредитування це стосується миттєвих
кредитів мікрокредитів які дуже часто
якими дуже часто користуються громадяни
4 млн за ть місяців лю громадян України
скористалися оцими миттєвими кредитами
під височенні ставки вони справді не
читають не думають як будуть віддавати і
до Чо і чим це їм обернеться це не ті
кредити які ви берете по карточці понад
ліміт грошей що у вас є це зовсім через
інші небанківські фінансові установи
коли ми говоримо що система Оце
мікрокредитування є для людей тяжкою в
плані незрозумілих відсотків і реклами
Які подають ці компанії все це наразі
намагалися впорядкувати і щодо того щоб
громадяни більш мали фінансової
грамотності і розуміли що вони беруть
під які відсотки беруть і все ж таки це
робили обдумуючи будь ласка чи читайте
кредитні договори читайте Що ви
підписуєте на жаль багато людей цього не
роблять і потрапляють в пастку коли не
їм нараховують про відсоток на відсоток
відсоток на відсоток і все це стає якісь
тисячі відсотків але при цьому треба
було зберегти існування таких
небанківських фінансових установ тому що
Зрозумійте що це гроші
е якби приватних осіб які заснували ці
компанії і які на свій ризик дають без
застави в користування громадянам тому
такий компроміс
знайшли майже погодилася галузь але щодо
зауважень які до цього проекту є Я також
говорила в залі ціла галузь наприклад
страховиків говорять що ви нас не почули
вони ставили свої поправки і свої норми
на засіданні комітету їх включали на
одну секунду ними зневажають а це люди
які надають робочі місця які
забезпечують певні сфери діяльності
небанківських фінансових установ
довідома всіх громадян буде такий
перехідний період для того щоби все ж
таки ці були е максимальні розміри
ставок е встановлені законом і ми мета
була така щоби хоча би вийти на рівень
не більше 1% денного тобто
365% річних це теж дуже велика сума
великий розмір відсотків але Зрозумійте
що що більше
50% в цій галузі є таких ризикованих
кредитів над чим вони потім працюють
компанії тому більше понижувати не було
можливості інакше це взагалі зникне і
тоді Залишиться тільки банківські
Кредити які видаються під заставу або
під певний ліміт що ви можете отримати
на свої
картки наступне питання в Україні існує
експортно-кредитне агентство
його мета - це страхування і
перестрахування діяльності по експорту
товарів і послуг що це означає заключає
експортний контракт українське
підприємство йому треба взяти кредит для
того щоби виготовити продукцію зробити
товар і так далі якраз під експортний
контракт під те що в нього куплять Ці
товари експортно-кредитне агентство може
виступити виступити з страховиком перед
банком тобто в підприємства немає
наприклад немає нерухомості Ну ви ви
знаєте що заставою це проблема треба щоб
була якісна застава щоб отримати кредит
так отк експортно-кредитне агентство -
це якраз ото ота гарантія застави яку
яка надається для того щоби підприємство
могло взяти кредит і працювало по цьому
кредиту Ну звісно правильна річ тому що
ми маємо підтримувати виробництво
по-друге ми маємо підтримувати тих хто
Може ще і і здобуває нові контракти на
експорт ну це абсолютно правильна річ і
вона має розвиватися все більше і більше
в нашій країні вносять пропозицію про те
що А давайте тепер експортно-кредитне
агентство буде страхувати е по кредитам
не експортерів майбутніх які вже мають
експортні контракти А тих хто буде
просто працювати в Україні і тоді
виходить що так а просто в Україні
працюють і інші підприємства які взяли
кредити тиждень назад які які працюють
там з початку
війни або на початок війни вони вже
вклали свою інвестицію і мають кредити
Так ми цим інвесторам Які наприклад до
війни тільки побудували якийсь проект по
переробці
експортноорієнтований але кредити
використали іноземні кредити і
зареєстровані національ банку вони зараз
не можуть обслуговувати ці кредити бо
вони по ним навіть не можуть платити
відсотки але ми вибудовуємо нову систему
Всі розуміють що грошей немає і людина
яка стоїть на трибуні весь час про це
говорить але як треба знайдуться для
окремих так званих програм А як же тоді
конкурентне середовище це найбільша
проблема яка є на сьогодні ми маємо в
Україні мати абсолютно однакові
можливості для всіх коли ми говоримо про
те що є ресурси доступ до яких має
обмежена кількість там підприємств чи
осіб які можуть їх отримати це створює
неконкурентне середовище страхування та
перестрахування від воєнних або
політичних ризиків окремих кредитів
окремим українським суб'єктам без
пріоритетів з розмитими визначеннями
навіть яких не може розібратися і
зрозуміти чітко що народні депутати що
Міністерство економіки призведе до того
що це буде чергова лазівка для тих хто
наближений до влади для тих хто може
домовитися і коли починаєш розбиратися З
усією купою питань то знову бачиш оцю
корупційну корупційну саме кормушечку
яку створюють через так зване
страхування це абсолютно очевидно що це
перебирання функцій і страхових компаній
і в тому числі якісь вибірко механізм
який буде діяти для вибіркових компаній
по роботі з вибірковими банками чого б
не хотілося бачити в нашій країні точно
І що точно не спонукає для інвестицій Я
думаю що ці норми ніколи не запрацюють
тому ми вирішили Не ставити на
підтвердження своїх 200 поправок
голосуйте ви робите це як завжди мене
одне радує що
60% законів які були прийняті тут не
запрацювали тому що под ним немає
підзаконних актів тому що по ним
виписані по гано механізми я розумію
чому опозиція так не любить нас важливим
проектом який розглядався на цьому тижні
в Верховній Раді Це був проект який має
на меті нібито побороти е виробництво і
експорт чорного зерна і вся проблема
виникла вже давно і була відома ще на
середині Минулого року в нашій країні е
діє достатньо тривалий час дуже брудна і
дуже е
погана схема зухилення від оподаткування
і зухилення від повернення валютної
виручки це вивезення чорного зерна за
кордон люди скупають заготівку це чорне
зерно оформлюють на фіктивні компанії
вантажать на кораблічі вантажівки А ви
знаєте про зерновий коридор морським
шляхом всі чорні експортери заплатили 5%
від оціночної вартості партії і попали
Таким чином на корабель куди заплатили в
карман декому чорну брудну готівку
Чомусь у нас завжди вибудовуються
такі такі пропозиції по подоланню схем
які народжують нові схеми і про це мали
би говорити довше в залі Верховної Ради
і і обговорювати цей проект там за
повною процедурою аграрії в шоці від
того що уряд запровадив експеримент по
наповненню системи яка би давала повну
інформацію щодо білих і чорних
виробників так от не її використовувати
при випу випуску продукції на експорт а
використовувати саме податкову систему
смкор слухайте якщо в країні всі питання
галузеві вирішувати через смкор то в нас
головним поліцейським буде в країні наш
голова комітету Ви цього хочете він всіх
переконує він на вас як удав діє ви всі
зразу погоджуєтеся що все треба приймати
ну Майте хоча б якусь силу протистояти
цьому нездоровому підходу до аграріїв ви
знаєте мені взагалі здалося що зараз
розпочався той же механізм який був на
початку роботи Верховної Ради цього
скликання в 19-му році тобто оцей
швидкий принтер тому що коли голова
парламенту говорить запишіться два за
два проти і навіть без
доповіді автора і рішення комітету то це
означає що вже голоси є вже все
домовлено немає чого тут обговорювати в
залі оскільки я дуже довго І намагалася
донести інформацію цю всю через свій
telegram-канал і писала декілька днів
поспіль про про цю проблему яка очікує
зараз наших аграріїв то варто все ж таки
зараз об'єднатися і до другого читання
не дати встановити жорсткий жорсткий
терор для а аграріїв тому що якщо ми
зараз все будемо запускати через
блокування податкових накладних а саме в
цьому річ саме в цьому річ що вирішили
що
Зупинити відвантаження чорного зерна на
експорт можна через блокування
податкових накладних Ну мені здається що
ви вже всі знаєте і вся країна знає І я
говорила це з трибуни Верховної Ради що
коли Кожен другий в протягом уже мабуть
останніх девти місяців зустрічався
стикався з тим що його діяльність
зупиняється через блокування податкових
накладних На жаль колеги я не розділяю
той спокій які зараз є в залі при
розгляді цих двох проектів законів ви
всі чули про блокування податкових
накладних ви всі чули про блокування
діяльності підприємства через відно
віднесення його до ризикових ви чули що
50% підприємств блокуються за цими двома
критеріями ви всі чули що таке смкор так
от тепер це буде стосуватися напряму
регулювання неповернення валютної
виручки то ви зараз побачите ще більшу
картину коли вибірково буде для деяких
аграріїв будуть реєструватися податкові
накладні До речі тепер треба бути
обов'язково платником ПДВ обов'язково
реєструвати податкову
накладну на 14% податку на додану
вартість на експорт обов'язково
проходити всі процедури по
ризикорієнтованому підходу який
виписаний для ризикових операцій а потім
іще і для ризикових контрагентів так що
вас чекають ще ті Випробування я просто
говорила і
говорю
що замість того щоб експорт розвивати і
точно контроль по поверненню валютної
виручки можна встановлювати в інший
спосіб запускають таку машину знаєте
коли не тільки тикань а повністю зупинки
діяльності поки будуть розбиратися чи
правильно чи неправильно зупинена
податкова накладна в цей час уже будуть
зірвані зобов'язання нашої сторони ми
станемо з негативною історією
постачальниками зернових і таким чином
нас будуть ще більше витискати із ринку